i don't know
how the black panther sequel is going to
say goodbye
to chadwick boseman
but i will say this
this is a hell of a sign-off story
[Music]
episode two what if
t'challa was star-lord
now i noted in my review of the first
episode that while it was pretty good
and i had fun with it for the most part
that it felt very safe and i hope to
that rather than being a template for
how the stories were going to go moving
forward that it was instead a more
grounded less deviating from the story
we already know story to get people
acclimated to what this would be before
they start going wilder with the things
and i am so happy to report it was the
second one
because
oh
this
look captain carter was
lovely it was great to see peggy kicking
that much butt but this is what i'm here
for
here the number of characters who get
roped in feel way more organic i kind of
complained how steve was turned into a
proto-iron man which i mean it's not the
end of the world in the previous one but
it made me go a little like oh you were
really struggling to cram other
characters into this this
it's it's a guardians of the galaxy set
up just bringing in all the cosmic
characters so and like they brought in
almost all the voices and pretty much
all of them are great i was a little bit
nervous with chadwick boseman because
you know it's an accent it's a put on
voice and i was worried about how much
he'd be able to convey about personality
with not his natural accent in an audio
only medium but he nails it he was so
good there is so much is brought across
about his personality and what
gravitates people towards him and all of
the cast almost all the cast uh was
really good michael rooker terrific
karen gillan wonderful sean gunn back as
craiglin they brought back the actor for
taser face oh jimin hanzo is korath he
is having so much fun in this josh
brolin is this version of theros is like
what what
about the only one who didn't quite work
for me
uh is actually someone who is kind of
suffering from what i was afraid would
be the case for chadwick bozeman but it
wasn't there but it was a little bit for
beniso del toro as the collector which
is that
del toro when he does his strange voices
it works in film because he brings a
physicality to it that sells the voice
he's using whereas here you lose that
physicality and they weren't really able
to recreate it with the performance in
the animation and so
the voice just sounds a little off
not quite stilted in the way that
sebastian stan did a bit in the previous
one but just a little like that's that's
not
quite working uh and i feel like he
would have sold it if he was physically
performing the part and like he probably
was in the booth but we're not seeing
that in a way that makes it all pulled
together but the k the way the
characters used still totally works and
this is
such a romp but more than that
i love the way it really properly
ripples out everything because
ultimately
once captain carter
you know got the super soldier serum in
the previous episode the overall
structure of what happened
was effectively the same as what
happened in the first avenger
here
this takes events
span events and characters spanning
guardians of the galaxy both volumes um
you know everything involved with thanos
and t'challa and black matter and all
these other things and mixes it all
together in a way they're like oh dang
and it really has a lot of fun with the
ripple effects of this one change
whereas
ultimately the change from steve to
peggy didn't change that much about what
was going on here
i love the idea that t'challa being so
fundamentally such a vastly different
person
from peter quill that that effect has
massive ripples
that spread so far to so many characters
it's so much fun to watch now i've been
avoiding specifics and spoilers up to
this point about the closest i've come
to spoilers is naming some of the people
who show up but given that it's
galactically said it's the cosmic
characters these are all characters you
should have expected to some degree to
possibly show up but if you haven't seen
it yet i'm gonna start getting into
spoilers this is just this is just too
much fun
now with lesser characters or with
lesser performers it would have been
very hard to sell the idea that t'challa
because of his personality would
actually change this much of the galaxy
that could have felt very cheap
but it doesn't partly because
not only of chadwick boseman's just
magnetism as a performer even in only
vocals but also
if you remember peter quill and how he
was and what a doofus he was you're like
yeah it's not just that t'challa is that
good it's that peter's that much of a
dork so it's it's not just like oh he's
really good but also the other guy is
way down here so the it makes it click
and i love that it happens like right
off when korath the pursuer sees him and
immediately recognizes him oh star-lord
it cues it right off the bat for not
only how different this is going to be
but the direction in which it's going to
be different i was kind of initially
boggled by the idea that thanos was
talked out of
um his entire plan
but the more i thought about it and and
watching the impact that
the somewhat more
easy to follow impact that t'challa had
on characters like yondu and craiglin
and all the ravagers
but then to see thanos and like to see
that thanos didn't really change as a
person he was still like it would have
worked
so to to see him like kind of holding on
to that idea but also be like no
no you're right and also what's kind of
fun about that is that the solution that
t'challa basically offers him the
redistribution of wealth and resources
is what a lot of people who felt like
being um plot hole nitpickers would
criticize about thanos like why is he
wiping out half the universe when he
could use the power of the gauntlet to
actually redistribute or increase the
amount of resources so
that is a criticism
i'm not actually sure that was actually
a valid question it's a criticism of the
character of thanos not like badly
written but like as a person it's a
flawed thinking process and it says a
lot about him that the first solution he
came to as well will kill half the
people um but i i kind of like that it
addresses a criticism that some people
actually had of his plan in the movie
and that somebody like t'challa could be
the one to explain to him like no no no
just hear me out here and actually get
him on board and then accounting for all
the ripple effects of that like the fact
that drax still has his wife and kid and
he's just tending bar now the fact that
thanos is uh the black order those four
are still around and they're still
dangerous they're just not following
thanos anymore the idea that thanos no
longer pursuing this path left a power
vacuum that the collector slipped into
all of these events and also like at the
very end accounting for the fact that
ego still wanted peter quill and and to
find him and having that have been so
giving us actually a little tiny taste
of that thing that i mentioned in the
previous review where traditionally what
if stories in the comics tend to end
badly
as a way to sort of reinforce the idea
that the universe that we get the main
universe is the best of all possible
universes because even though this sci
story multiverse alternate thing is fun
it ultimately would have turned out very
badly and this manages to imply that
that would happen without actually
having to show it and have it end on a
bummer note because you can choose to
believe okay yeah i can see where this
would be a problem because now peter
quill doesn't have the
backing and the history and the support
network that would pull him out of ego's
orbit the way that he did in guardians
of the galaxy volume 2 so maybe now
we're screwed but also maybe not this
entire universe is different maybe
they'll find maybe other people will
find a way to stop this anyway so you
don't have to see it as a down note but
it is still able to evoke that thing
that is as i said is kind of traditional
to the comics a few people seem to think
that i was implying that that's how the
show should be i didn't actually mean
that i just found it interesting that
that's usually the tone of the comics as
an ending point so here despite just
being wonderfully fun from top to bottom
they're still able to evoke that a
little bit without bringing the mood
down that's a nice trick
and i love all the little details they
remember to account for like the
collector's assistant who kind of
goes against him in that first guardians
of the galaxy movie here the thing
remember yeah no she's still gonna be
holding that grudge so let's account for
that and apply for it the fun that was
had with howard the duck without having
him take over the story which that was
nice that was enjoyable just the fact
that nebula had hair and like the fact
that as much as t'challa might have
helped yondu find different purpose in
life yondu still yondu and yondu is
still gonna do some things that are a
little bit screwed up so again kind of
like thanos accounting for the fact that
how t'challa was able to change the
direction these characters were headed
but not fundamentally change who they
are as people so you still see the bits
and the glimmers of who they were like
like with both thanos and with yondu and
a little bit with nebula with the the
scheming on with her there so it is able
to do these really well balanced
adjustments on the characters to set
them on new trajectories without feeling
like a complete betrayal of who they are
this has really just been a gushing
ramble because this
was so much fun
like to the point that i'm a little bit
worried would this be the second one
like this is such an upgrade from the
first one and i enjoyed the first one
but this is such a higher mark to hit
i am a little bit afraid that the series
has already peaked i don't know if it
can get better than this i hope it can
at least keep meeting this mark cause
dang
this was really good i mean if i'm going
to
level any kind of criticism on it i
still don't love the animation style i
still feel that fundamentally it works
much better when it is a action scenes
or b they are using it to recreate
specific shots from the movie so like
when they are recreating that opening
scene from guardians of the galaxy
with t'challa and korath in this
animation it looks good because this
style of animation does a very good job
of looking almost exactly
like the original film did so for those
things it's very good but this is also
an episode with a significantly larger
portion of talking versus action the
last one had a bit more of an action
focus whereas this one because
t'challa's kind of main thing is
actually talking these people around to
his way of thinking then that means that
there is a fair bit more talking in this
there's still action in it the action is
great and the talking scenes thankfully
are saved by the performances and the
story going on but again my eyes get
drawn to the mouths because that's just
where my eyes tend to focus on things
and the mouths are probably the worst
part
and they they look the least convincing
and again part of that's on me but it's
part of why i don't like this animation
style and i never will but you know what
it says a lot that i can be watching
something in a visual style that i don't
care for and that hasn't turned me
around to make me think yes this is in
fact a great way to do animation
but i'm still sitting here gushing my
head off
about how good this is
oh
it was so much fun to wake up and watch
this first thing in the morning i need
more days to start like this dang
what if t'challa was star-lord
oh
man
it's really good what did you think of
this one whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it i have a patreon it's how
i pay my bills and it keeps this entire
operation up and running i've also got
other social medias for you to check out
besides but uh
no pressure
like share subscribe help me out as well
but at the end of the day my friends
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you
[Music]